you know what loki i do think you're
onto something
love is a dagger can seem
small something that maybe you'll just
always have
and then it can save your life or cut
your heart out
no maybe it doesn't work never mind
low-key episode three lamentis
so this is mostly our chance to get to
know
sylvie who is uh now the
rechristened lady loki and we find out a
fair bit about her
although she's reluctant to give too
much information
but i still i found what we did find out
intriguing
before i dig too much into that i do
think it's worth pointing out i'm
starting to get a little bit
frustrated with the pace of the show
overall knowing that it's as short as it
is
i had kind of hoped for things to pick
up
pace wise i was prepared for the first
episode to be
almost entirely set up cool i can work
with that
i was fine with the second episode
largely being
you know the the pursuit and having it
feel
almost procedural in a way pursuing
this variant that we now know is sylvie
but when you ended the previous episode
with the entire timeline getting
bombed and still be vanishing
and loki in pursuit i wasn't expecting
the following episode to be as laid back
as this one
was i mean we start out with actiony
bits uh
she'll remember that can't use magic at
the tva
but sylvie still kicking butt and then
we just
deposit her and loki on a completely
completely different planet
that is about to be destroyed so yes
there's something they have to deal with
but you've
removed them from the building sense of
stakes we had because you were building
a sense of momentum around
the damage that she was doing and also
the tva in general and the timekeepers
in terms of what's actually going on
there
because you've signposted so much that
like it's not what they
say it is and while we get a couple of
threads pulled on that
for the most part it feels like the
breaks were pumped on the story that was
happening
so that we can now do a side story and
i wouldn't mind that as much if this
series was longer but it's only six
episodes
so uh i feel like
that the better thing to do would have
been to either
find a way to cut this divergence or
if you needed the slower pace of this
if you needed to pump the brakes in
order to give us time to get to know
silvia a bit better
then maybe you shouldn't have pulled the
trigger on the bombing of the
uh entire timeline quite yet because
that
set us up for momentum that this episode
doesn't carry through
that having now been said i don't
dislike this episode i don't think it's
bad it's just the first bit of notable
frustration i've kind of had with the
show
overall in terms of its general pacing
anyways i'm going to be spending most of
this thing
just talking about sylvie i think um
because there are a couple of bits and a
couple of points that i'm like
oh yeah i've got mixed feelings on but i
also get what they did
so let's actually start with the name
she has taken on a new name
and she very harshly rejects
the name of loki so
i i get why they did this
i was personally a little bit
disappointed but this is for inc
reasons incredibly specific to me so
they're setting up sylvie
as basically a trans woman
variant um or an equivalent
thereof you know the mystical magical
using equivalent
of that um the reason that's notable to
me is because when you have things on
like on a dossier where it says sex
fluid i had
been hopeful that the uh inclination
would be something more like
gender fluidity um which is my
experience
so when she so harshly rejected the name
of loki i kind of raised an eyebrow a
little bit now
this isn't true for all gender fluid
people but again speaking to my own
experience
the kind of experience that i actually
kind of never really expect to see
reflected back
in entertainment but like every now and
then i think maybe
and then usually not um
you know i don't reject my birth name i
use more than one i answered a vera but
i still answered a nathaniel which is
the name i
i was born with and i don't reject it i
don't have dysphoria around it
so i had kind of hoped to see something
like that but
i can't actually fault them for going
with a
bit more of a trans woman style approach
where
she it's the term isn't used but she
seems to
uh approach the name loki like a dead
name
which uh is honestly in the grand scale
of things
probably the better idea to go with if i
were to step outside my own experience
because since
gender fluidity in general um especially
as a as a real-life experience is not as
well
known or understood then it probably
wouldn't have been the best thing in the
world to do
what to some people was going to read
like a trans woman and have her be
totally cool with
an old masculine name like i understand
why that would have been a bad look
i absolutely do but i still can't help
but have a i have a little bit of oh
from myself in that that said there's uh
some interesting tidbits that come
out uh in regards to
how she developed as a variant we don't
get a ton of details which i think is
probably for the best the more d
the more details and the more specifics
we get the more things might not add up
so there but there were a couple of
things she said that made me go
oh okay and kind of support some of the
stuff that i was thinking
because in terms of the variance we've
seen
it wasn't totally clear if this show was
treating you know because we saw
that little compilation of variants and
some of them looking very very different
and this it wasn't clear the show was
just treating it like every
possible alternate version of the time
was just wildly different it's like a
butterfly effect thing
or if it was a case of whatever it was
that caused them
the any given loki to be a variant to
be off of the intended path
was somehow tied to why they look
different or depending on how
long they'd lived while uh while being a
variant might contribute to how
drastically different
any given loki would look so we find out
from her that first of all
her variance seems to happen very early
in life
it um you know she wasn't
under any illusion that she was adopted
as a
as a child and my first thought was like
oh
so like did the tva not pluck her out of
the time stream early on
um when maybe they should have was for
some reason like was that
detail not addressing enough change but
then she
says and again not without super details
she says later
i've been running from these people
almost all my life
and i'm like oh oh
okay so what that is implying
is that yeah the variant point from
which she diverges with this loki is
early in her life
and pretty close to when that happened
she has been running from them ever
since
so that first of all explains a lot of
the differences in their approach why
she is much more
sort of mission focused she has to focus
up
if she doesn't focus she gets caught she
gets killed
whereas the loki we know spent a good
chunk of his time just
having a laugh which we see at play here
on the train and so i feel like the
little bits that we're getting about her
history and about how she got to where
she is
and again like i don't need full
explanations i'm liking little bits i'm
getting but i feel like the little bits
we're getting
are accounting for the differences
between them
pretty well i am liking that i like how
the enchantment
uh works and how it gets talked about
a little bit um i i like the idea
that with some minds it takes more work
and she has to basically construct a
false reality
for them for the person she's enchanting
to interact with
so that she can get what she wants out
of them
that's a neat idea so i'm i'm down for
that
the this was an interesting thing and
something i
hadn't occurred to me like it's our
first absolute definitive the
timekeepers
aren't what they say or the tva is like
stuff's messed up
but the information that that young tva
agent
was at some point just a human and then
silvi drops that the entire tva is
staffed with variants
i'm a little annoyed i didn't think of
that but here's the thing
it makes absolute sense
because you think about it the way we've
been seeing them
deal with variants for the large part
was just what they call pruning them
just
removing them from the time like killing
them effectively
but like why have a
judge why have a trial system
if you're just gonna prune them the
trial system is a vetting process
to figure out whether or not they can
use
any variant within their system
and make use of them in the agency
i'm i'm again i'm a little frustrated
that i didn't think of that before but
once that occurred to me i'm like oh
yeah
and as loki pointed out they don't know
that
so there's your definite okay
all right stuff screwed up um and i'm
not sure if i'm 100
standing by my conviction that the
timekeepers are
dead and or never exist well here's the
thing uh
it's distinctly possible that they never
existed as we see them portrayed in like
the little video like the space lizards
as loki likes to call them
but i've seen some people float the
ideas uh potential spoilers i suppose
i'm getting speculative now
i've seen some folks float the ideas
that
the timekeepers are also low-key
variants
um who just managed to
like either get in there first or to
take over the thing
or who knows so uh like
it's gonna be something like that at
this point there's no question that
there's a twist with the time keepers
coming because now we know there's
something
sinister about them they can't be
trusted like yeah
no question stuff's gonna go on there um
i really did like the
interactions and the dynamic and the
frustrated chemistry
between sylvia and loki but honestly a
big part of why that worked is their
quieter moment when they get to just sit
down on the train
and just talk if it had been nothing
but the frustrated back and forth
between them
i probably would have gotten tired of it
it would have worn on me after a bit but
taking the break taking the time to slow
that down and have them have this
quieter moment
which i wouldn't be surprised if the
entire basis of this episode was largely
built around
getting them to have that moment um
although my
um criticism about how it flows overall
in the series still stands
but it's really good stuff and i
i love i love her taking a rest and
loki just being like oh i'm going to
party now
that was wonderful he's got a decent
singing voice as well which was nice and
they snuck it in on you because most of
the thing is like this
sort of drunken almost shouting and then
he slows down and gets into actual
saying him like oh
that's nice and then back to the shouty
bits that he steals
thor's i like this another
fun little callbacks like that um it was
an
odd point to end the episode on
again i think that kind of circles back
onto my criticism of the pacing of it
because since this whole thing already
felt like a divergence
in service of character development and
relationship growth granted but since
this already felt like a divergence the
fact that it's not
fully wrapped up by the end of the
episode
is a little irritating now i expect that
this is a cliffhanger that'll get
resolved
within five minutes at the start of the
next episode
i have little doubt about that but it it
led
to a a little bit of dissatisfaction
with the overall feel of it because
okay just to compare how this ends to
the very previous episode
i would the the previous episode was a
great
setup and it set things up in a way that
like i don't know what's going to happen
next because you just went in a
direction
and started him down a path where i
don't know where that goes
and i was excited and fascinated this is
a bit more of a traditional cliffhanger
in the oh how are they going to get out
of this situation scenario and i don't
think those kinds of cliffhangers work
very often
especially halfway through a show
halfway through a series where the
threat seems to be
the lead character and a new primary
second day character are going to die
i'm like well no they're not
you know that this is this is bad
classic era doctor who style
cliffhanger you know oh the oh look the
doctors that yeah we know
the doctor's not dead and you're gonna
resolve that immediately in the next
episode so
it's kind of frustrating especially
given how good
an endpoint the previous episode had in
terms of getting me pumped up and
excited about what was going to happen
next and now they just like oh
is it's a cliffhanger it looks like
they're going to die
i'm like oh god's sake so like
i'm kind of mixed on this episode i
think overall
it's placement of the way it flows
across the series i'm a little bit iffy
on
and in terms of the
the end point i'm like oh why but there
are a lot of really good moments across
it
i like their interactions i like their
moments on an individual basis
i like that they are able to kind of
work together and complement
each other in terms of their techniques
and other times just basically
bashing into each other and bouncing off
it it's a good
balance it they are they are similar
enough in some ways while being
different enough in other ways that it
makes good chemistry
so they i would like to see more of them
together i want to see more of these two
just being around each other and coming
to understand each other
i'm very much here for that
um but the overall
structure and the overall story that
they decided to put
those interactions in i don't think
is the best that this could have done
especially considering like we just had
uh an apocalypse in our in the last
episode so the fact that they're on a
planet that's about to be destroyed
isn't that unique either i mean like it
makes sense that
you know sylvie probably had a bunch of
apocalypses programmed into this thing
so when
they clash and you know they just end up
at one of the apocalypses it makes sense
so it's not like i'm going massive
coincidence on it but like we just had
an apocalypse
did like so sending them to another
apocalypse
is not as interesting as as i think the
show thinks it is
i'm still like i'm still here for it i
still am
pumped for the next episode i will be
happy to see where they go from here i
just hope the overall
flow to the thing goes a little bit
smoother
next time around i think that's about it
um yeah i'm gonna wrap it up there
thanks so much for watching listening
loki what'd you think about episode
three
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it i have a patreon
link up there that is how i pay my bills
if uh you are able to help me out at all
it's greatly appreciated but if you
can't don't worry about it
the likes share subscribes also help me
out there's also youtube memberships if
you want to go that way but you don't
you don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day you are
the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
foreign